welcome to this video playing Adele know
from from France is going for the London
sister early Bishop f4 yeah okay this is
this type of line with out 90 or three
years a bit a bit more interesting then
when the night is already on f3 let's
see is this Queen B 6 mm I cannot
remember at the moment
okay I can also play in a keep it simple
fashion just setting up a solid position
looking like looking like I'm the
caro-kann exchange there's nothing i'm
especially great but certainly
satisfactory for black okay i'm going to
go for trying to prepare be 5 p.m. yeah
maybe yeah an all-night ef5 is not
really leading to much that's a very
very solid position if i go bishop the
age how does he protect a five let's see
he's not protecting it so I'm just
gaining just winning this this porno
maybe with the bishop or not
take it with the night before I return
akin will be five but that's not leading
two of two very much
now if slightly awkward piece position
so this is this is a slide slide ischium
knight c6 is not not really great here
maybe I should play b5 first year b5
asking white to retreat with the Queen
so that i get the c-4 square yeah the
set was that was a good good idea
probably maybe also night for him yeah
so that c4 is even even easier to go to
exchange of this this night
okay i might go to to see five but if i
go here I'm attacking imma checking
between
okay so if i go bishop to c7 is he going
to to sacrifice them it's probably not
really going to work but anyway is going
for this ok I wait wait a moment asics
hangs
that's very unfortunate didn't really
impatient your attention to this okay
it's not really terrible but I simply
simply didn't really didn't see that
really okay with 97 I'm going to get
this exchanged on ID form after the
bishop is going back to g6
our ponds are slightly devalued here all
night b7 notices probably something I
should I should go for my e6 bond is
weak but his c3 porn is not not any
better rook c8 c6 look Lucy eight would
be good I have before now maybe do that
come on let's try to try to set rehab
now attacking d 4 + b 3 I didn't feel
like I'm playing a plate so slowly still
I'm clearly behind on the clock check
check ok so clean here may be attacking
each one be three and freeing up the
Jeep on to move
d 4 D 3 might be the next move
one minute ten this is still ok to want
want it hanging so how am I going to
continue Quincy three maybe yeah Quincy
three is I'm warning you cannot take it
the pawn will promote and a threatened
to do a threaten to take on safari are
probably
okay didn't have much time him yeah he's
unfortunately quick with the beep horn
I need to get the king over I need to
keep his King at bay which didn't didn't
didn't work out very well ok I'm going
to take take him
I can take a can can go back now check
check I cannot push the edge porn
without the King King Air Force what's
really silly I know don't tell me that I
really I really managed to lose stuff at
the moment that's really unbelievable
learning the guys is this is this is
rhonda who is worse the whole game for
for nothing they managed to even use it
that's really difficult check ah that's
a shame check check just stumble into
the simplest tricks on earth just King F
or whatever yeah it's it's okay i did
that aaron King g5 I can also go go
ahead I mean it's it's useless it's it's
it's like a helpmate or how I'm playing
here yeah it's still a draw you can
paint whatever you want it's my opponent
doing the same yeah f + 10 times winning
before of course managed to find the
only only loss possible okay thanks for
watching